大須俺果たし今日はポケモンを捕まえるわけじゃねーから私服代の時は皆さんだい
にんき5分カードやってますでしょうか
一説によるとなんか波戸氏が流行らせたみたいな噂が立っていますけれども6万吹け
カーはまりましたっていうのを言っただけでウットネードみんなハマンないと思う
ポケが実際にそれでやってみて面白いから今なくすぐになってるわけなんであのウイ
綺麗だとか
[音楽]
俺のせいにしないでくださいぜひ今日ポケモンカード話なんですけども
ポケモンカードを売ろうと思いましてん
ポケモンカードですが決してそんな中やめるとかそういうのじゃないですポケモン
カードということにはレアリティというのがありまして例えばですよヴィエリえって
言う
山部だからカードが知ってるって強いのがあるんですけどもこの莉美へとコノリーで
値段こんなに差があります
同じ効果のに2つも同じですよ同じ今回なのにこんなに
下がるのやばくないですか北小積もってますツイマジでやばいと思いますから持ってる
のたぶん今3万円ぐらいなんですけど勝ったときは4万円ぐらいしましたからね
これが大人って俺はもう大人を超えだ大人なんです音などが働くとヤップお金を持って
出すんねをなぜ効果たとしてもなんかよくわかんないけど高いの買ってしまっていうね
変な起きるんで
単にそういうなかったねーんだろうやっぱ愛加奈あいかわかんないですけどやっぱ
こっちの方がかっこいいか
同じ効果でも高いほうを買っちゃったりするんですよ他にもねば同じポケモン同じ
カードなのに光り方が違うだけで値段が全然変わったりするんですよ例えばこのヅラを
ら全然これ値段が違いますこっちのがめちゃくちゃ高い
で僕は
これたくさん打ってますわかる人にはわかると思うんです結構大変なことになってるん
ですよ値段とかねただここが同じでも安いものがたくさんあるんで僕は大人になって
こういうレアリティの高いレアな方で集めた時期が終わって更にステップアップして
大人の上をいってしまって逆に良い効果をな
だったらリティー関係ないんじゃねっていうそれで駄目って言ってるわけじゃないです
けど僕はから練り t 日に始点の中だせーなーみたいな
京都に辿り着いてしまったんで今日の動画ではキラキラ光って老朽なポケモンカードを
全部打ってみようと思います荒らすん
波戸氏これだかも5000円のかで買ったんですけども普通にも300円とかで同じ
合格数あるんですよ同じカードはもったいなくないその4900円で何が出来るん
だって思ったとき僕は他の使い道があるんじゃないかと思ったわけですよ
というわけで打っていきますもうなぁでキラキラなカード片っ端からありますからね
では行こうおっぱい乳あげてこれで全部じゃないんですけど結構ピョン母が集めてまし
てやすいカードでた誰がいるんだったら安いかといった酒
絵はいいやと思っちゃってよね母どちらギランにする為に俺はポケモンかで売ってるよ
ねー
楽しけりゃいいあるだけなんだよ
なんでおりますやっぱり一番高級なんだこれが本当にねリーリエちゃんってか4万円
ドアで買ったんでめっちゃ高いんですよまあそういうのはどれだけ売れるから問題の
ポイントになっていくと思いますねであるカード版出していきましょう
[音楽]
俺はもうねさん4年ぐらいカードでもやってきたんですけども気づいたんですよ
まあこうやってリアリティただしまうあとに話します
k 死んでないからデッキをなくすわけじゃないんで同じ効果の俺より安いカードに
すぐ入り買えちゃいます
4枚のガードがー6こいこい
me
んああああ
大うんちょっと負け確認しました僕が得るものは変わりがあるレンズの高いカーボン
ブレーキだしてるカード色違いも結構高いんで色違いも全部売ります緯度違わない
カードを使えばいいだけなんでちょっと並べてみましょう
はいという気で並べ終わりましたもう名からに伝わって欲しい物キラキラ感全てが
キラキラになっております何度南区なんですけどここらへんだもん
2回伊勢をグズマンとか d とかめっちゃ高いんですけど日常
これだけ売りますこれを全部打って果たしていくらになるのでしょ
いやーちょっとマジでやばいと思いまー相当高いと見てる俺だって4万円で買ったやつ
あるかねここまで6戦6戦6戦6戦とかこれまで5戦でカットしていやー怖い公約は
本当に来
これ全部打ったところで僕が来強化できなくなるわけじゃないんで効果が全く同じで
やすいくカードがあって誰でも楽しめるのがポケモンカードの素敵な所ですだから半年
目覚めてしまいました安いやついいんじゃねってここで綺麗に米カードキラカード
放り投げて初診の心で考えゲームやっていこうとハ年を持っているんだ女は売って以降
は耐えようぜっ
に酔うぞさおー近いてあげましょういや様キャラだからいいけど
だったです
たらいんちょ cafe
はいというわけでやってまいりましたお店の前まで到着したんで早速
二外科のやばいギラギラな者だけ全部打ってくると思うあんなに集めたようにまずで
行っちゃうん
光っているカードもノーマルカードも効果は同じまたしが上
もううわぁウォンとは聞いてきますって言ったらスーツ
[音楽]
大変驚いてください
それ相当サテン時間かかって来なかった
a いきますねいやーこえこえこえこえこえ
と合計前で60名でござい猫打ったスネお値段のほうが大
うん
分
270,000円
ああああああ
ファウストなんだけどねえ世界は85,900円でした
いやでもすっごいちゃんにー27扱いずらしーいー
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
60枚で畑がなりたいんだから一番した今超えて感じですよええ
いやーけどちょっと思ったより良い巻買ったと思っちゃったら
高野組室1でポケがた台みたいに水が誰かちょっとアレなんですけど
60万円で活鰻ご請求だけでございます395あのメロディー関係ないですよ癖が
楽しめばいいと思ったんで結果高い乗るだけでも8万円くらい
なるという話でした
アルダじゃん